supongamos que estás volando un papalote
con un amigo quien se encuentra a 40
metros de distancia sosteniendo el
papalote cuya cuerda tiene una longitud
de 30 metros también al medir el ángulo
entre el papalote y el piso donde tú te
encuentras determinas que este es de 40
grados y te preguntas si podrías
utilizar el poder de la trigonometría
para encontrar el ángulo que se forma
entre la cuerda del papalote y el piso
te invito a que le pongas pausa el vídeo
e intente resolver por tu cuenta este
problema con los datos que se tienen
siempre que nos encontremos con
problemas relacionados con triángulos
que no son rectángulos lo que tenemos
que considerar es si podemos aplicar ya
sea la ley de senos o la ley de cosenos
así es que veamos en este caso cuál es
la que podemos aplicar la ley de cosenos
nos dice se cuadrada es igual a cuadrada
más b cuadrada menos 2a de coseno de
teta y lo que está estableciendo es si
tenemos nuestro triángulo
de los lados son a b y c y el ángulo
theta que es el ángulo formado por ahí
ve y si por ejemplo conozco dos lados y
el ángulo entre ellos puede encontrar el
tercer lado o si conozco tres lados
podría encontrar este ángulo pero ese no
es el caso que tenemos aquí queremos
encontrar este ángulo donde está este
signo de interrogación pero no conocemos
tres lados queremos encontrar este
ángulo sin conocer tres lados así es que
no es obvio que se puede aplicar la ley
de cosenos quizá podría encontrar este
otro ángulo pero aún así no con los con
los tres lados que pinti bien contra el
valor de este ángulo podríamos entonces
aplicar la ley de senos y la ley de
senos establece que si yo tengo un
triángulo como este y este ángulo le
llamo a este ángulo le llamo b y este
ángulo le llamo c ya este lado opuesto
le llamo c mayúscula a este lado opuesto
a minúscula le llamo a mayúscula y éste
le llamo b mayúscula la ley de senos nos
dice que la razón entre el seno de un
ángulo y su lado opuesto permanece
constante es decir seno
minúscula / la mayúscula esto es igual a
seno de b minúscula entre b mayúscula lo
cual a su vez es igual a seno de s
minúscula entre c mayúscula veamos si
podemos aplicar esta ley en este
problema conocemos este ángulo y el lado
opuesto y el lado opuesto entonces
podemos escribir esa razón seno de 40
grados entre 30 y esto es igual a
podemos decir que esto es igual a seno
de este ángulo entre este lado si podría
ser pero desconocemos estos dos valores
así es que esto no nos sirve de nada
pero si conocemos este lado entonces
podemos usar la ley de senos para
determinar este ángulo y posteriormente
determinar el tercer ángulo que nos
falta así es que si este ángulo le
llamamos teta y esta distancia es de 40
metros entonces esto por la ley de senos
tiene que ser igual a seno de teta sobre
40 esta razón es igual a seno de 40
grados sobre 30 y ahora simplemente
despejamos teta multiplicando ambos
lados por
del lado izquierdo estos 40 se cancelan
y del lado derecho me queda 40 sobre 30
que son cuatro tercios cuatro tercios
que multiplica a seno de 40 grados y del
lado derecho nos queda seno de eta ahora
para despejar teta tomamos seno inverso
a ambos lados tenemos entonces seno
inverso de cuatro tercios
que multiplica a seno de 40 grados y
esto es igual a teta eso nos va a dar
este ángulo y ya obteniendo este ángulo
podemos obtener el ángulo que nos
interesa en este problema sacamos la
calculadora deja de verificar que esté
en modo de grados eso es muy importante
listo entonces calculamos el seno
inverso de cuatro tercios que multiplica
a seno seno de 40 grados y esto cuánto
nos da suenan los redobles y esto nos da
58 punto podemos redondear no vamos a
dejar las centésimas
esto es 58 puntos 99 así es que este
ángulo teta es aproximadamente igual a
58 puntos 99 grados así es que si este
58 puntos 99 grados este ángulo de aquí
va a medir 180 menos el valor de este
ángulo menos el valor de este otro
ángulo de nueva cuenta la calculadora
fue
tenemos 180 menos este ángulo que es 40
menos este de aquí que acabamos de
calcular podemos recuperar la respuesta
anterior con esta función seconds y nos
va a dar toda la precisión del número
así es que esto nos va a dar 80 y 1.013
vamos a redondear a nivel de centésimas
esto va a ser 80 y 1.01 así es que este
ángulo de aquí este ángulo de aquí es
aproximadamente igual a 80 y 1.01 grados
y así hemos concluido